[Musique]
pendant la période de confinement vous
savez il ya pas de produits importés
donc déjà ça a été un débouché accru
pour la production nationale française
ce qui est ce qui est en même temps cet
la crise des transports la difficulté de
traverser la france fait que le local a
été une redécouverte pour à la fois les
distributeurs et la distribution a été
une redécouverte pour des producteurs
qui ne pensaient pas la grande
distribution capable de vendre leurs
produits
et ici à rambouillet comme un peu
partout en france les gardes de local de
produits locaux ont pris une grande
extension et surtout il ya eu des
contrats qui ont été signés qui
permettent finalement d'espérer dans le
long terme que cette relation perdure
[Musique]
les modèles de distribution ne se
ressemblent pas les centres leclerc sont
des indépendants comme système u comme
intermarché et donc ils sont
complètement libres de n'offrir s'ils
veulent que du local bien évidemment il
faut offrir ce qui est demandé par le
consommateur qui est lui-même affluence
et par la publicité par ses propres
besoins
les enjeux de la relocalisation c'est de
donner une explication aussi au
consommateur sur la qualité des produits
sur le fait que derrière l'achat de
produits il ya de l'emploi derrière il
ya de l'emploi au pays
c'est une possibilité pour les
agriculteurs aussi pour les producteurs
de valoriser leur production de ne pas
tomber dans la banalisation et après
tout qu'un produit soit labellisé charte
rambouillet c'est une valeur ajoutée qui
donne droit à une rémunération
supplémentaire